I'm going to give you a fellow wide
receiver and you're telling me how you
would cover them I bet let me put my
corner hat on and we're going against
Gabe Davis how was you going off
coverage Inside Out being as physical as
I can at the top because he's big what
about Jamar Chase Demars really built
like a little mini like running back
strong I just got to play Bump the whole
time that's your best chance and even
then you probably don't got that good of
a chance Justin Jefferson another
another LSU gun bump and running I might
need some help actually have you some
help over the top I'll be as aggressive
as I can at the point of contact what
about Tariq you know what we said we
need some help imma actually need it
this time stay all the way over the top
and we still might need an extra guy but
you said you could beat him in 100 yard
dash I was saying that but that wasn't
that wasn't an accurate statement what
about Gary Wilson he's young so I mean I
would actually try to just mix it up
with him a little bit like play outside
play inside switch up my leverage a lot
he Shifty like real shifting okay let's
let's reverse the roads and let's say
Trayvon played receiver he would catch a
bottom let's talk about stuff regarding
stuff you can